today we will be explaining all of
garo's forms in one punch man there is a
total of five forms to cover along with
his God form at the end is there a form
in which he is strong enough to defeat
saitama the answer may not be what you
think even in his regular human form
garo's strength is superhuman and he is
easily an S-Class level he is an
extremely skilled fighter who adapts to
combat and uses the advantage of the
opponent's weak spots to give himself
the upper hand in fights his super
learning ability allows him to mimic
other people's fighting styles he used
this ability against genos where he
copied Watchdog man's fighting style and
movements furthermore by analyzing his
opponent's line of vision posture and
muscle tension he can effectively
predict their next attack Garo is also
incredibly fast being able to
effortlessly dodge a Firebase attack
from blue fire and rip his arm off
before the hero could even realize what
happened he is also able to sense that
people are watching him as he realizes
he is being watched by two monsters
despite being engaged in a battle
against metal bat at the time as well as
being able to sense killing intent very
clearly his senses are also sharp enough
to enable him to deflect a baraz of
shots from a Gatling gun flawlessly
without letting a single shot hit him
red Garo after being pushed to his
limits in a series of fights against
teams of A-Class and S-Class Heroes
garo's Evolution begins in this form his
hair and one of his eyes turn red he
fought against both bang and bomb
simultaneously in this form but was
almost beaten to death one of garo's
defining traits and a factor that allows
him to keep fighting even when on the
brink of death is his sheer willpower
this willpower is evident throughout the
battle against his former Masters as he
was always able to continue fighting
despite all of the injuries his idea of
becoming a genuine monster and spreading
fear across the world plays a big role
in his incredible willpower motivating
him to accomplish his goals no matter
how many difficulties he may face so far
Garo is nowhere near saitama's level but
his most powerful forms are yet to come
before we continue any further we want
to thank rage Shadow Legends for
sponsoring this video Rey's got a ton of
Champions over 600 now all of those
Champions come from unique fact each
with their own history in the world of
telluria personally my favorite faction
is the High Elves their Homeland aravia
has been around for thousands of years
surviving the fall of the lizardmen
Empire and defeating the Orcs when they
attacked the continent the Civil War
nearly ended the elves but Arabia
survived rebuilt and now it's stronger
than ever my favorite champion from The
High Elves faction is definitely this
guy I mean his name is literally Jaeger
it couldn't have been more perfect raid
is currently running a huge series of
Summer Splash events where you can get
some incredible skins for everyone's
favorite dwarf trunda they're also
bringing out five badass looking new
Champions and overhauling the champion
Vault there's currently a special
deliana Chase event where you can get
the amazing deliana a brand new
legendary champion from The High Elves
faction moreover once they're in game
just enter promo code my deleona to get
50 XB Bruce to instantly get your
legendary hero deleona to max level 50.
as well as a ton of silver this is the
best time to get started in raid and if
you click my link in the description or
scan my QR code code you'll get unique
bonuses worth thirty dollars we're
talking a free epic Champion virgis 200
000 silver one energy refill One XP
boost and one ancient Shard so you can
summon awesome Champions as soon as you
get in game half monster Gara after
being almost killed in a fight against
Royal Ripper and Bug God garo's power
explosively increases and his clothes
merge with his body causing him to
slowly transform and only his face
remains untouched as a result of being
pushed to the brink of death and
overcoming it his limiter starts to
break and he is identified by gyroguro
as being a half monster this is garo's
first major transformation but is far
from the last one his senses and
abilities increased dramatically and he
is able to fight his enemies even while
he is asleep in his half monster form
Garo was able to put up a good fight
against super alloy dark shine although
he suffered great injuries from his
attacks as a result of appearing to
break his limiter garo's abilities can
increase immensely in a very short
period of time as their battle rages on
garo's abilities increased to the point
that he can match the S-Class Hero's
full power super Ally bazooka who his
own attack without any difficulty or
damage his strength eventually increases
to the point where he was able to
pressure and harm the hero both
physically and mentally before tatsumaki
interrupted their battle he later went
on to fight far more powerful foes such
as overgrown Rover yoro Giro and Orochi
in Rapid succession before being
defeated by the latter complete monster
first form eventually Garo nears his
transformed monster state with most of
his body morphing devilish horns appear
on his head and his clothes are reduced
to only his pants and scarf not a single
trait of his former face remains during
his fight with bom and his evolved State
the latter was surprised by garo's
escalating fighting style and commented
that through his battles Garo has
combined various techniques and refined
them into his own style as bang arrives
the master and the student face off
again the two engage each other and it
seems like a balanced matchup Garo
manages to make his former Master bleed
after a brief Clash Garo suddenly takes
this stance of exploding heart release
fist utilizing his new fighting style
Garo is able to overwhelm bang pushing
him back and significantly injuring him
Garo then demonstrates his roaring Aura
Sky ripping fist to the shock of his
master they both attack each other one
last time and attempt to land a
finishing blow bang successfully punches
Garo in the face while Garo simply
grazes bank's chest however the
Shockwave from garo's blow is still
strong enough to cause his former Master
to fall to the ground defeated after his
battle with bang Garo was able to
swiftly combat an overwhelm three dragon
level monsters in a fraction of a second
later he was capable to keep up with
flashy Flash and platinum s in combat
and all three of them were so fast that
a geometric structure of light was
created from the speed of their fight
after flashy Flash's defeat Garo engaged
in a one-on-one battle with Platinum s
and increased his speed even further
exchanging seemingly hundreds if not
thousands of blows with the foe within
milliseconds complete monster second
form after saitama punches Garo and
sends him crashing into the ocean Garo
gets out now totally wet and angry he
feels so much rage and Views saitama as
a block to his ambition of becoming
absolute evil he begins to transform
again protrusions appear on his back and
shoulders and his horns get more curly
let's just say that his demonic features
are now more visible and Garo now
resembles an epitome of evil with his
body getting far bulkier than before
while the transformation is going on
Garo is able to hold a little
conversation with tario a kid that he
saved before and tells the young boy to
watch closely while he shows him the
powerlessness of Heroes garo's strength
and speed are massively increased in
this form he attacks saitama Landing a
punch at point-blank range while the
force and speed of the punch appeared to
be insane however saitama doesn't even
get scratched from it shrugging it off
like it was nothing this already sets
the tone for the entire fight as Garo is
still very far away from saitama's
levels the one punch man slaps Garo and
sends him flying away reinforcing the
fact that while this transformation
might have increased garo's overall
strength it changes nothing in their
battle as the Fight Continues we see
Garo use saitama's lack of martial art
skills against him he is able to quickly
land a hit on saitama's Bald Head
following it up with a punch to
saitama's face and completes the triple
combo with an elbow this is really a
move that you will be proud to pull off
in a fighting game Garo continues to get
more and more impressive in this form as
he counters saitama's attack throwing
him to the ground his impressive streak
does not end there as he unleashes God
Slayer instant attack a move that
utilizes Lightning Fast punches and
pummels the Baldi until saitama is
eventually able to break away Garo
wouldn't let him rest as he attacks with
the god Slayer ascending combo a move
that sends one punch man crashing into a
building the destructive effect of this
attack is something that I can't wait to
see animated Garo receives a serious
headbutt from saitama which frustrates
the hell out of the wannabe monster and
causes him to undergo yet another
transformation we will soon talk about
garo's Cosmic God form but let's first
explain his final monster form as Garo
begins to transform again due to his
anger he gets bulkier and bulkier as his
muscles increase in size another
noticeable feature is that his body is
seemingly covered in armor and his horns
are a bit different but the standout
feature here is the demon wings that he
develops in this form yeah you heard
that right Garo can now fly as they
continue with their battle even saitama
acknowledges garo's strength increases
in this form with a combination of speed
and strength Garo begins to flex his
Newfound power as he punches saitama
into a volcano and flies right at him I
don't know about you guys but some of
garo's designs remind me of demons in
Black Clover and to be honest all the
forms look so cool as the battle rages
on we get a real test of durability for
garo's new form as saitama gets a clean
punch in at his opponent surprisingly
Garo receives little to no damage as he
easily shrugs off the strike it has to
be said that boros received severe
damage from taking these punches while
Garo just tanked one to the chin he
seriously deserves some credit for this
over the course of the fight Garo begins
to get more and more frustrated as he
cannot harm saitama in any way the one
punch man even deflects a slew of
attacks from Garo with just one hand
showing their vast difference in
strength Garo resigns himself to his
fate that saitama is stronger than him
as he states that saitama is the
embodiment of unfairness at this point
one punch man hits him with some regular
punches and a final punch that destroys
a lot of his monster armor and a lot of
his body reverts to his human form
Cosmic form this is the form Garo
assumes after escaping the body take
over by God in his fight against saitama
its appearance is that of a featureless
void filled with galaxies and stars his
silhouette is reminiscent of how he
looked after his fight with super alloy
dark shine how strong is Garo in this
form and most importantly can he really
defeat saitama having received powers
from God Garo has also gained knowledge
of all energy flow as well as the
behavior of all forces in the universe
he is apparently able to control the
energies of the universe as he pleases
this allows him to deliver extremely
powerful blows of cosmic energy in this
form Garo has become the symbol of fear
that brings all heroes to despair in
other words the absolute evil he is able
to use his energy manipulation combined
with his punches to generate Atomic
blasts these blasts are powerful enough
to be detected by nuclear detection
tools psychos refers to these blasts as
divine power likening them to homeless
Emperor's energy spheres Garo is also
able to use his energy manipulation to
summon the same phenomenon of the gamma
ray burst for those of you who don't
know gamma-ray bursts are immensely
energetic explosions that have been
observed in distant galaxies when he
uses this power the area around Garo
becomes a miniature Singularity and he
releases two parallel beams of energy in
the direction he desires this attack is
powerful enough to make saitama think
that it would be bad if it only even
grazes the Earth one of the new
abilities this form has granted Garo is
shaki it is the secret martial arts
technique that borrows the power of
nature by imitating the movements of
living things Garo refers to them as
modes which he thinks sounds cooler
using this ability the techniques garum
copies also get owned to Perfection at
incredible speed rendering the original
user soon unable to catch up to the
duplicated techniques as of making this
video saitamas and garo's fight hasn't
yet finished but from what we have seen
he is fully capable of holding his own
against saitama and even Landing some
punches against him this is definitely
the most epic battle in one punch man
that we've seen so far and we can't wait
for the next chapter click on this video
where we explained all 30 36 Dragon
level monsters don't be shy click it